sur cette scène je vous parle de
beaucoup d'objets connectés beaucoup
d'objets différents que ce soit des
smartphones des tablettes des pc des
montres et de pas mal de choses et
aujourd'hui je vous parlais d'un produit
qui est extrêmement surprenant je suis
sûr que vous le connaissez pas je suis
quasiment sûr que vous le connaissez pas
se produire
il s'agit d'une montre du nom très
particulière regardez la bien à votre
avis à quoi peut bien servir cette
montre est ce que vous avez une idée on
ressert un petit jeu on sent un petit
jeu pour commencer je vous laisse
deviner à quoi peut servir cette montre
vous mettez la pause le marquer en bas
en commentaire vous marquez à quoi peut
bien servir cette montre qu est-ce que
cette montre qu a déjà fait le tour de
ce côté là je vais essayer de me
contorsionner de l'autre côté on a fait
quasiment tour elle est assez grosse
elle est assez épaisse elle sert à une
chose quasiment vraiment une chose en
particulier
à vous de deviner le marquer un banc
commentaire mettez la pause marquée mans
à quoi pourrait bien cette montre et on
verra à la fin si vous avez raison ou si
vous aviez tort alors c'est une honte
pas comme les autres qui dit montre 10
heures effectivement c'est une montre
qui d'honneur à des vous le voyez là
c'est une montre qui donne l'heure ça
c'est son truc principal ça me paraît
assez normal mais elle ne fait pas que
ça le fait beaucoup mieux et fait
beaucoup plus que ça et à mon avis ça
risque vraiment de vous surprendre
regardez moi la taille de gros bébés
regarde-moi ce bracelet il est quand
même hyper hyper hyper monumental
alors en fait cette montre est là une
vraie grosse particularité c'est qu'en
fait regarder au niveau du bracelet que
vous l'enlevez vous avez tout de suite
voir c'est extrêmement particulier voilà
ça c'est la montre vous avez donc un
bracelet principal qui sert à
l'accrocher qui pendouille que vous avez
ici tous les côtés et vous avez un
deuxième bracelet central qu'il ya
vraiment venir ceinturée votre poignet
qui va vraiment obtenir votre foyer vous
avez trois boutons sur le côté
un cadran bien évidemment qui indique
l'heure parce que oui c'est une montre
mais c'est pas une honte comme les
autres parce qu'en fait cette montre est
là une innovation qui est là pour vous
sauver la vie cette montre c'est un
tensiomètre c'est un tensiomètre nomades
mobile que vous emmener partout avec
vous alors vous connaissez probablement
si vous souffrez de problèmes
d'hypertension artérielle des
tensiomètres mobile vous pouvez emmener
avec vous il faut quand même le prendre
il faut l'installer
ça c'est extrêmement discret pour être
avec des amis dans un resto pouvait être
à une soie pouvait être quelque part
même faire du sport un moment vous vous
isolez vous poser un petit peu et vous
pouvez venir mesurer votre pression
artérielle yvo de boer extrêmement
facilement pour ce faire il suffit de
vous vous positionnez comme ça prenez
votre monde
la pause est contre votre coeur vous
appuyez sur le bouton dessus et la vie
reprendre votre tension artérielle
premier petit gonflage pour voir si elle
est bien positionnée et ensuite ça monte
alors normalement il faut se chercher
des paris doucement pour pâques et une
erreur parce que normalement il faut
absolument pas parlé voilà résultat j'ai
une tension à 11,8 et j'ai un bouquet à
70 on n'est donc pas sur une montre les
sur intention d'être mobile attentionnel
connecter une application je vous montre
ça dans quelques instants qui vous
permet de vous monitorer tout au long de
la journée tout au long des exercices
tout au long des phases de repos pour
savoir exactement comment foutu bonne
tension artérielle et pourra montrer
ensuite tout ça directement à votre
médecin en crise et surtout super super
bien et le fait de venir l'intégrer
comme ça c'est bien parce que ça évite
les personnes qui doivent mesurer
régulièrement impressions et ariel de
malades et quand tensiomètre de diane
kruger je m'écoutais justement qui
censure m là vous le faites c'est
discret et personne ne sait que vous
avez un tensiomètre à votre peau ni pour
par contre l'inconvénient c'est que vous
avez quand même un truc qui a ses
masters qu'au poignet
c'est vraiment énorme va l'autre côté il
faut bien pouvoir la mesurer donc voilà
ça fonctionne comme ça mais dans
l'absolu ce trouve que la montre est
plutôt pas mal
le packaging est bien faite à casillas
et discret en tout cas c'est rigolo
c'est le système pour recharger en fait
c'est très bizarre c'est un espèce de
système de pince à mon avis n'ont pas su
comment intégrer l'usb celle là dessus
non plus haute est quelque chose de très
très particulier alors bon une fois
qu'on relève le bracelet comme ça on
voit qu'effectivement il n'y a rien pour
venir brancher votre montre ici pas du
sbc sur les côtés absolument rien de
l'autre côté non plus ici là donc on se
dit comment est ce qu'on va recharger
cette montre est bien fait regarder si
vous jeter un petit coup d'oeil par ici
vous avez deux petits connecteurs qui
sont positionnées juste là et c'est tout
l'idée de cette petite pince alors cette
pince elle est constituée d'un petit
câble micro usb usb à de l'autre côté
vous venez vous branchez votre micro usb
là dedans pour trouver les petits
connecteurs ici voulait positionner pile
poil en face se retrouve très très
facilement dans la halle j'y suis
directement lapin s'est vraiment faite
pour ela en fait vous allez branché et
vous aller charger votre monde tout
simplement le fonctionnement de la
montre en lui-même est vraiment
extrêmement simple trois boutons premier
bouton du haut qui va actionner la prise
de tension vous allez appuyer la bombe
pop
j'annule ici parce que j'ai forcément
j'ai pas la montre au poignet le bouton
hutus qui vous servira pour revenir à
l'écran principal et le bouton là qui
vous montre votre historique
ça c'est ma dernière prise de tension
11,8 taper à 70 c'était tout à l'heure
j'ai filé quelques instants
deuxième bouton sa mesure et mon nombre
de pas bon j'ai pas beaucoup beaucoup
marché aujourd'hui je ne vous le cache
pas donc 2 kg calories brûlées
vous avez ensuite votre historique de
sommeil et vous venez directement menu
principal autant vous dire qui a pas
grand chose à l'intérieur il n'y a pas
grand chose parce qu'il ya juste
l'essentiel omron s'est dit ok on fait
une montant se mettre on va pas faire
une onde connecter un petit peu plus
standard ya pas l'application vous
n'avez pas d'eau est ce particulier
derrière vous avez juste ces quelques
fonctions de base à l'eau je trouve ça
marrant mais font c'est aussi un peu
limitatif
lorsqu'à votre smartphone est connecté
pour sauver vos notifications dit mails
de sms et d'appels
vous pouvez absolument pas ni consulter
vos sms niveau email et ni répondre à
vos appels depuis votre monde mais juste
savoir que vous avez reçu un ok c'est
tout alors je trouve ça bien mais c'est
un peu dommage aussi parce que cette
petite monte là et que quand même le
prix de 549 euros il ya beaucoup de
technologies il ya 80 brevets à
l'intérieur pour réussir à vous faire un
tensiomètre dans une montre donc
effectivement il ya un certain coup
c'est un produit qui n'est pas du tout
destiné à tout le monde sa chronique est
extrêmement riche et s'introduit que
j'imagine va pas de vendre en grande
quantité mais qui pourra rendre vraiment
services à toutes les personnes qui
veulent mesurer et suivre très
facilement leur pression artérielle et
qu'ils ont derrière les moyens de mettre
549 euros
dans un ultime mesure bon à côté de ça
la montre en elle-même elle est plutôt
pas mal
d'un point de vue esthétique quand vous
la regardez comme ça mais dès que vous
la mettez de côté elle devient très
énorme et très gros sabots de police ali
pendu poignée de chacun ça dépend de la
morphologie de chacun moi qui ai un
poney qui est pas très très gros
voiliers tout de suite elle est assez
mastoc à mon avant bras
par contre il faut quand même savoir qu'
elle n'est disponible que en taille m
il faut que la circonférence de votre
poignet face de 160 à 190 mm sinon ça ne
marchera pas par contre une application
qui est assez marrante qui est planqué
justice'' earth advisor de morrone vous
cliquez dessus et l'avoir trouvé pas mal
d'informations directement dans votre
smartphone vous la synchroniser vous
avez un aperçu global qui va vous
montrer votre dernière tension
artérielle votre activité physique le
nombre de pas la période de sommeil le
pos actuel tension artérielle ça vous
montre votre suivi au cours de la
journée
ce camp mais vraiment d'avoir un vrai
vrai vrai monitoring également au niveau
du pour votre activité physique le
nombre de spas ou émettre des objectifs
j'ai fait un pour cent de mai lui il
passe mon objectif autant vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui c'est vraiment pas fait
grand chose
la même chose au niveau du suivi de
votre poids vous avez tout votre
historique ici tension artérielle
activité physique sonnailles poids bon
c'est un peu la même idée en fait avoue
le retrouver au niveau du jour semaine
mois autres vous pouvez vraiment me
personnalisé pour avoir une vue globale
sous forme de court et ça chauffe ça
vraiment bien pour les personnes comment
il fait plus réellement le besoin vous
pouvez venir programmer des rappels par
exemple vous dire à ta leur soit faire
une prise de tension est à l'heure de
faire la main et tout à l'heure à telle
heure à telle heure comme ça vous n'avez
plus à vous prendre la tête à regarder
leur ses vêtements qui vous dira
directement et vous avez tout un profil
pourrait venir paramétrer personnalisé
paramètres du compte informations
personnelles les paramètres de
l'application faille à pas mal de choses
sauf que c'est quand même assez bien
on est vraiment focus sur la pression
artérielle le pouls le sommeil et le
poids par contre ce qui est vraiment
bien c'est que pouvaient venir partager
les données que d'autres applications
google fit samsung santé ou alors
qu'environ connecte à la question est ce
que la home run and bike est une monde
connecté la réponse est clairement non
elle donne lui a effectivement c'est un
tensiomètre deux poignets qui ressemble
à une montre qui donne l'heure mais
c'est un tensiomètre de poignées s'est
pas réellement unique alors en fait je
dirais que ce produit sur un petit choc
se produit il est vraiment destiné à des
personnes une fois de plus vous en
douterez je voulais dit qu'ils ont
besoin de mesurer très facilement et qui
veulent vraiment ne pas s'embêter à
emmener leur temps à se remettre avec
eux donc ça c'est possible ça ça marche
bien c'est un super produit c'est un
truc il niche et parce qu'il coûte aussi
très cher 549 euros
voilà c'est pas donné à tout le monde
c'est pas à la portée de tout le monde
je trouve que c'est un produit qui est
bien mais qui mériterait vraiment évolué
pour avoir pleins d'autres applications
qui t'amène à 149 euros autant avoir
pleins d'applications l'intérieur ça me
paraîtrait vraiment aller dans le bon
sens lapointe que vous êtes extrêmement
limité mais c'est vraiment ce que
s'arrêter sur ce produit qui ressemble à
une montagne monde connecté mais qui en
fait n'est pas une mode connecté qui est
un tensiomètre connectés et c'est tout à
fait pas grand chose d'autre et c'est un
peu regrettable quitte à bord un écran
couleur et avoir un truc aussi épais
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas venir y mettre
une petite fonctionnalité deux mondes
connectés avec un os derrière je pense
qu'encore a plus de boulot de la part de
m road là dessus parce que c'est pas
parce qu'on veut mesurer sa tension
artérielle et qu'on veut la voir sous
forme de montre qu'on doit avoir une
monture funes a pas grand chose donc si
vous êtes amoureux technologies vous
voulez acheter ce produit vous l'avez
donc d'un côté et si vous voulez une
monde connecté il vous en faut une autre
à dos de poney l'autre côté autant dire
qu'à un moment
voilà ça marche pas ça c'est vraiment
jeune rêve le point négatif
je pense que mon run a besoin d'aller
plus loin sur ce produit cameron a
besoin d'installer un système google ça
me paraîtrait vraiment bien et ça me
semblerait en tout cas que dans le bon
sens parce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaires sont aussi une vraie belle
avancée pour toutes les personnes qui
ont besoin de ce monitorer très
régulièrement et qui veulent pas
forcément emmener leur transmettre avec
eux qui veulent pas forcément dire à
tout le monde
j'ai des problèmes tension artérielle il
faut
non là vous le faites vous viso les 30
secondes comme ça c'est fait et ça il
faut que c'est vraiment cool a vous de
me dire ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire est ce que vous êtes dans la
cible est-ce que vous avez besoin de
vous monitorer régulièrement et est ce
qu'on produit comme ça pourrait vous
tentez à 549 euros
mark et moi tout ça quant à nous on
retrouve dès demain on continue par les
textes nous sommes à demain ciao